i'm grateful for
the opportunity to take part in the
discussions at the forum
the main theme for this year's divorces
history at a turning point government
policies and business strategies this
year
they were its turning point
appears to become more than just a
rhetoric figure of speech this is really
the moment
when it is decided whether brute force
will rule the world if so the force is
not interested in our thoughts and
there's no need for further meetings in
davos as there would be no reason for
that brute force seeks nothing
but the subjugation
it has been turned into a house of
russian war crimes and this is an
example of their transformation
what russia has done to itself but
becoming a state
of war criminals and what it brings to
the world
it inspires
other potential aggressors to act
instead of successful peaceful cities
there's only black rooms instead of
normal trade sea full of mines and block
ports in ukraine instead of tourism
close skies
of russian bombs and cruise missiles
this is what the world would like
if that turning
moment
would not have a proper response from
the humanity it would resemble a large
set of war crimes
so history remembers many moments when
everything changed dramatically
for example
several shorts fired
could kill millions of people if those
shots were fired on june 28 1914 in
sarajevo
history remembers how much grief
one person
can do
if it can see it can understand that
it's not being properly resisted
as it was for example in 1938 in munich
some historical twists and turns were
noticeable some not
but we always had to respond to them
trying to prepare for other historical
upheavals
so is to mitigate the possible
consequences or trying to heal the
wounds out of catastrophes that followed
one or another historical twist
and now we have a large collection of
such responses there's un charter with
all these
agencies the osce the iaea the wto and
many other
institutions
but
are there enough of those
to respond to what we have faced
today is it possible now to try to adapt
those institutions for modern challenges
definitely not we need to change the
approach
not to respond but to act preventively
[Music]
look at what ukraine has already done we
have
didn't listen to those who said that our
defense would not hold longer than just
a couple of days we have stopped the
russian army which was called the second
largest in the world at the coast of
heavy farting at the coast of thousands
of lives we're gradually pushing the
occupiers out of our territories but
would we
and a full range of sanctions would be
applied against russia
that could knock down
any
aggressor
i'm sure the answer is no
preventing war
could be guaranteed should the sanctions
of the world would be preventive and not
just
imposed as the response ukraine has set
another precedent in the three months a
president for the unseen unity of the
democratic world around the emotions
of genuine admiration for ukrainians
courage and around the understanding
that you would need to fight for the
freedom and now hundreds of millions of
citizens in democratic countries
are putting pressure on governments and
in companies to make sure they would
limit or restrain their relations with
the aggressor state with russia
and instead to help the people
under attack but this is happening only
now
even though russia started its war
against ukraine back in 2014
we are grateful for this support but
if that happened
immediately that's unity that pressure
on governments and companies
for the sake of the fight for the
freedom would russia start this
full-scale war would it bring all these
losses upon ukraine and upon the world
i'm sure
that the answer to this question
is also no
now
we see that the world listens
and
believes ukraine but there's also a
certain expectations of the world as to
how the situation will be resolved what
tools will work
what
can we create to prevent such
aggressions in future and how do we stop
the brute force
that
that's what the turning point means
ladies and gentlemen
don't expect for the fatal shorts
don't expect for russia using their
special weapons either chemical
biological
and
more so nuclear do not give the
aggressor the impression that the world
would not resist enough protect
the freedom and regular
peaceful order in the world with the
maximum efforts possible that is what
the sanctions should be they should be
maximum
so that russia and every other potential
aggressor who wants to wage a brutal war
against its neighbor would clearly know
the immediate consequences for their
actions
and i believe there's still no such
sanctions against russia and there
should be there should be russian oil
embargo
all the russian banks should be bogged
no exception
there should be an abandonment of the
russian i.t sector there should not be
any trade with russia this should be
a precedent for sanctions pressure that
will work convincingly for the decades
to come
and would support
the peace
it is necessary to set a precedent for
the complete withdrawal of all foreign
businesses from russian market so that
your brexit brands would not be
associated with war crimes so that your
offices bills and goods were not used by
the war criminals and their bloody entry
values
must matter
particularly when a full-scale war
begins and the global markets are
becoming destabilized because someone
someone there
is simply neglecting the values
in that case everyone suffers losses
we offer
every company that leaves the russian
market to continue operating in ukraine
you'll have access not only to our
market of 40 million consumers but also
to the common market of europe and
your brands your positions they will
only increase
because you would truly support the
protection of freedom our
representatives here in danvers can
inform
all of you on the details of the
prospects that ukraine opens for your
businesses ladies and gentlemen
we offer the world to set a precedent
for rebuilding the country after the war
which will show everyone who dreams of
destroying the life of a neighbor that
the war is not working
i invite you to take part in this
rebuilding the amount of work is
enormous we have
more than half a trillion dollars in
losses tens of thousands of facilities
were destroyed we need to rebuild entire
cities and industries
and we offer a special historically
significant model of rebuilding one each
of the partner countries or partner
citizens or even partner companies will
have the opportunity to tag patreon over
a particular region of ukraine it could
be a city or community or even an
industry britain
denmark the european union and other
leading international entities have
already chosen a specific area for
patronage in rebuilding and thanks to
this model of relations
the post-war rebuilding could be fast
could be efficient and could be of high
quality and this would
not only allow to attract the best
specialists architects engineers
builders developers managers
and others but it will also
be the largest in europe
since the world world war ii it will
become the largest opportunity for an
economic
way forward and i hope that at the
beginning of the international
conference in lugano that was mentioned
by the president cases it will be held
in july this year dedicated to the
post-war reconstruction of ukraine all
of our partner countries and most of the
leading companies of the world will come
up with their own packages of proposals
taking this opportunity i would like to
extend words of gratitude
to switzerland for organizing this
conference and supporting our efforts i
would like to
know the efforts of usually underlined
particularly her proposal to establish a
platform for rebuilding and
reconstruction
uh that would be managed jointly by the
european commission in ukraine and will
allow to direct the european union
resources to restore the normal life in
our country
the list of the new presidents that we
need would not be complete without a few
more decisions
there has to be a precedent for
punishing the aggressor
and for the investments in the peaceful
life the russian assets
which are scattered in different
jurisdictions must be found
it has to be
seized or frozen
and then they should be allocated to a
special fund
that would be used
to help all those affected by the war of
course this is not easy
but after that there will be definitely
no
motivation of every aggressor to do what
russia has done and what it continues to
do if the aggressor loses everything
then it definitely deprives him of any
motivation to start the war let's move
on
any
should be stopped only preventively when
it's not yet started but now
the world simply has no tool like that
and we propose to establish the
organization for responsible and
democratic states exporters of food
products who can act
with respect for human rights and global
trade rules the motivation
for us is very simple whatever the
turning points they are in history
the humanity should have
a tool to protect itself against the
hunger and ukraine is ready to provide a
platform for the activities of this new
organization which is definitely an
important one and one more aspect this
war of russia against ukraine convinces
everyone
that support to the country under attack
is the more valuable the sooner it is
provided weapons
political support
and sanctions against russia
if
we would have received them by 100
of our needs
at once
back in february the result
would be
tens of thousands of lives saved this is
why ukraine needs all the weapons that
we ask not just the ones
that
we've been provided that is why ukraine
needs funding that's at least 5 billion
us dollars per month
and all the
funds
that we need for rebuilding our country
this is why we have established a fund
for rebuilding ukraine called united 24.
and we call
upon everyone
to join this
platform
how to help and where to allocate those
funds where are those priorities
the targeted nature of our work is the
absolute priority
under this brand united 24 we propose to
establish a global structure
that can
within 24 hours can provide sufficient
support to any country
that has
suffered or faced a military attack a
natural disaster or a pandemic so we
offer a new format for security
guarantees
based on what we have faced
what we have went through
and there must be something that sets a
precedent for
a timely assistance to everyone who
needs it
to save
all the necessary elements for a normal
economy
for example
something like 911
there has to be a
similar service that is called united 24
which would guarantee the security on a
global scale
ladies and gentlemen a man whose name is
still well remembered george marshall
said the following
back in 1947
he said our policy is not against
a country or a doctrine but against
hunger
political and social conditions
in which free institutions can exist
these words
are relevant even today my proposals
are
all the same there are designed to
counter the hunger poverty despair and
chaos and of course the war
which is unleashed by the russia
and which brings nothing else but hunger
poverty despair and cows to many in the
world not only to us to ukraine because
guaranteeing
peace and instability and security
requires all of us acting quickly and
preventively we should not be afraid to
set new precedents
and this is what the world should learn
at various turning points to which it
paid a high price
this was the prize
for the fact that the world
would only respond but not to act
preventively so now we can do it
differently
finally in the correct way thank you for
your attention glory to ukraine
sir that was president zielinski of
ukraine there addressing the world
economic forum a couple of points that
he made there he opened his remarks by
saying that ukraine was gradually
pushing the occupiers out of their
territories and then he went on to urge
delegates at the world economic forum to
go and visit russia house which is
previously in a main exhibition on the
main drag the promenade in davos which
has been used by russian business to
promote uh russia's economy it's been
turned this year by ukrainian artists
into a russia war crimes house he urged
delegates to visit that president
zielinski then went on to say that he
felt him future sanctions should be used
for preventative means to try and
prevent attacks like the one on his
country by russia rather than simply in
response and he again repeated his call
for an immediate embargo on all russian
oil and said that all businesses should
pull out of russia's